are
thrilled to have a very special guest
with us today on jobs day a remarkable
job say it is um
dr cecilia rouse chair of the council of
economic advisors because we're running
a bit late she has a very small window
but has agreed to take a few questions
and also to come back and then we will
have a briefing as long as we can for
those of you in the pool we will keep
you updated as well so with that i'll
turn it over
good afternoon
so i really appreciate this opportunity
to talk about today's job report as this
is a bright spot and a sign of our
strong labor market recovery over the
past year
the february jobs report is extremely
solid
the economy added 678 000 jobs in
february well above market expectations
revisions to the prior two months added
over 90 000 more jobs than originally
reported with an average monthly gain of
582 000 over the past three months other
data demonstrate our strong economic
rebound the unemployment rate ticked
down to 3.8 percent and the labor force
participation rate ticked up reaching a
new pandemic high
since president biden took office the
economy created 7.4 million jobs this
includes the
greatest single year of job growth in
american history and the fastest
economic growth in almost 40 years
this month's report reflects broad-based
growth for example the unemployment rate
for workers with less than a high school
degree is the lowest on record and
employment in all major industries
either grew or held steady
last year the economy created more
manufacturing and trucking jobs in any
year since nineteen ninety four
while the care industry is still behind
the overall labor market in terms of its
recovery we saw meaningful increases in
nursing and residential care child care
and state and local government which is
often schools
notably this month also saw the largest
over the month increase in employment
and home health care on record
these are important components in
helping those with care responsibilities
get back to work
we look at the prime age labor force
they cannot find a full-time job or
because business conditions are weak
but similar to the long-term
unemployment rate this measure has seen
rapid recovery the percent of the labor
force that is working part-time for
economic reasons picked up in february
to 2.5 percent but remains below its
level in february 2020.
monthly employment and unemployment data
can be volatile and payroll estimates
can be subject to substantial revisions
therefore it's important to focus on
trends rather than data in a single
month which is what the administration
stresses every month thank you and i'm
happy to take questions
you've seen a
fairly substantial slide in the stock
market this year we've seen rising oil
prices those are obviously pressures on
the economy um do you think that if
those trends continue that they will
reverse the gains that you've seen so i
think it's important to separate the
the stock market from the real economy
and the the growth that we've seen in
the real economy has been the fastest uh
in almost 40 years we've seen job growth
that historically fast you know
obviously we have we are monitoring the
financial sector uh the the actions of
the federal reserve play a key role
there and obviously the tensions uh and
the the invasion of russia of ukraine is
having an impact there so we are
monitoring we are impacting but quite
honestly we go into 2022 from a position
of economic strength that the bones of
this economy are strong and it has the
resilience to whether what is ahead of
us in this year
excuse me data is fluid and volatile
right now but
given the strength that the us economy
has how long can it withstand the spikes
we've seen in commodities just the
general uh environment before the threat
of tipping and recession becomes real at
this point
so look the economy is very strong what
we saw in february was that we added
almost 700 000 jobs over the month as
the cases of omicron were coming down
but did not get down to zero so what we
saw was the the resilience in this
economy that we were able to continue
the recovery as we're also learning to
live alongside of this pandemic and
safely get back to our normal lives so
we are optimistic if we continue the
president has that we have the tools the
president has asked for congress to have
additional tools which we know are going
to be so important as we the pandemic is
not over but we know we have the
therapeutics we have the resources to
develop vaccines quickly we've got
masking we have the tools to navigate
the pandemic as we go forward so we are
optimistic that we can continue this
robust recovery this president has an
economic plan to grow this economy from
the bottom up middle out it's premised
on uh you know making the key
investments in this economy that have
not been made over decades so the
bipartisan infrastructure law was a key
component of that and there are
components of his you know what were
parts of buildback better which is the
you know child tax credit which is
investments in children paid leave which
helped people balance work and and home
responsibilities helping people get back
to work and balance their care
responsibilities lowering costs for
families whether it's in prescription
drugs child care costs that have been
increasing for decades and that are so
important to this economy so this
president is focused on that kind of
economic investments which are premised
on increasing our economic capacity
which is the kind of sustainable
economic growth that we that we're
looking to see okay um
given the good news that you just
mentioned and the trend lines which have
been very positive why do you think this
president is not getting credit from
voters
for steering the economy in the right
direction well i think that's a really
complicated question we know that
the american rescue plan was really an
insurance policy for this economy what
we know is that there are millions more
families we created you know the economy
created 7.4 million jobs over the past
year during this presidency um and so we
know millions of families are able to
you know have a job and put food on the
table and pay their bills
what we know in the consumer in the
confidence data a lot of that is premise
on inflation and we do have inflation
the president has acknowledged that we
understand that he is focused on that um
but what people also report is that
their own finances are fairly healthy
but they see the kind of uncertainty in
the economy uh that that is there so we
are we we're a pandemics guard society
that's not just the economy there's
uncertainty as we navigate our way out
of this pandemic and then the tensions
you know between russia and ukraine are
going to add to that uncertainty as well
if you describe the strength in the
economy if there were a policy decision
made
to stop importing russian oil what
impact would that have and do you see a
resilience in the american economy to
withstand that
so again we're in a very good position
what we know is that that you know from
the u.s economy we don't import a lot of
russian oil but we are looking at
options uh that we can take right now if
we were to cut
the u.s consumption of russian energy
but what's really most important is we
that we maintain a steady supply of
global energy
last one josh sorry just to follow up on
that we're reporting right now that you
are considering a ban on u.s imports
pressuring through your answer just now
that it might be more targeted than that
so we are considering a range of options
but what's really essential is that we
maintain a steady supply of global
energy we don't want to disrupt local
that energy is a global market and we do
not want to disrupt that market you know
these report the the jobs number was
great the wage growth was pretty
sluggish wondering is that normal to
expected there is one typically follow
the other
and what do you draw from that how can
you get wages to keep pace with the
actual job numbers themselves so from
month to month data can be volatile and
so we don't that's why we don't focus on
month-to-month changes especially in
like wages but we did see robust growth
even for lower in lower wage industries
and we know that over the year wages are
up but the president's economic plan is
really about
having increases in wages that are
sustained by increases in productivity
and they're really premised on the
increase in the economic capacity and
that help families by lowering costs on
those you know in those areas healthcare
prescription care child care that we
know have been really squeezing pocket
books over several decades thank you
for joining us thank you welcome anytime
okay um i just have two items for all of
you at the top um
i just wanted to provide i know we
announced this yesterday or the day
before but a brief overview on two
critical urgent funding needs the
administration has sent to congress
first to provide assistance to ukraine
the united states has already provided
over 1.4 billion dollars in assistance
to ukraine since 2021 and together with
our european allies and partners we are
holding russia accountable for its
unjustified and unprovoked invasion to
continue this important work we're
requesting 10 billion dollars to deliver
additional security assistance for
ukraine to uh to provide life-saving
humanitarian assistance for the
ukrainian people and more support for
stronger sanctions enforcement and for
u.s troop deployments to reinforce
nato's eastern flank and deter russian
aggression this is an urgent priority i
think everybody would agree democrats
republicans the american people uh and
it is urgent that we can continue to
deliver on our commitment to support the
ukrainian people second the other part
of our uh request
is on covet 19 response while we now
have tools like vaccines treatments
tests and high quality mass to protect
people we didn't get here by accident as
a result of wise investments over the
past 14 months that led to this
widespread availability and i would note
that we did that while we had the rise
of two variants that weren't even
planned for of course uh where they were
planned for but we didn't we had to
account for them i should say in our
spending uh we need additional funding
from congress to secure more medical
supplies to keep this country moving
forward and let me be very clear this is
an urgent request and this is what is at
stake in our fight against covet by may
our current supply of monoclonal
antibodies will stock out by july the
current supply of pre-exposure
prophylaxis drugs used to protect
immuno-compromised people will stock out
funds are needed in march to secure
additional supply in july you have to
order them ahead so that you have them
when they're needed when you run out of
stock by september we anticipate our
supply of oral antivirals will run out
if additional pills are not purchased
now so and within weeks we expect expect
testing capacity to drop if additional
investments are not made soon and as i i
would note in the president's state of
the union he also announced the american
people can order more tests so there we
obviously want to meet that demand
given how costly covet has been with so
many of our fellow americans
hospitalized or dying and our daily
lives disrupted we simply cannot afford
to wait on investing now and keeping
people protected i also just wanted to
give you a preview of the week ahead on
tuesday the president will travel to
fort worth texas
to speak with veterans caregivers and
survivors about addressing the health
effects of environmental exposure such
as burn pits obviously he talked about
this priority in his state of the union
address earlier this week it's part of
his unity agenda for the nation he
supports legislation that would expand
access to health care and benefits for
veterans affected by the these exposures
during military service and he was
encouraged by the passage of a
bipartisan bill in the house just
yesterday wednesday evening the
president will deliver remarks at the
senate democratic caucus retreat on
thursday sorry ms sneeze at some point
um on thursday
i just wanted to not scare anyone uh the
president will welcome the president of
colombia
to the white house to celebrate 200
years of positive diplomatic relations
and consult on a range of regional and
global issues of mutual interest during
their bylat the leaders plan to reaffirm
the bilateral relationship and discuss
covet 19 response future pandemic
preparedness economic recovery and
regional responses to migration that
evening he will deliver remarks to the
democratic national committee members at
their winter meeting and on friday he
will travel to philadelphia where he
will deliver remarks at the house
democratic caucus retreat i would note
that friday is also when we will be
marking
the anniversary of the american rescue
plan i'm sure you all all be celebrating
with us uh voluntarily or not uh so uh
we look forward to that um with that
colleen why don't you kick us off
um so president biden has promised that
there's going to be no american boots on
the ground um and he's also
acknowledging that the war in ukraine is
going to impact pocketbooks um we see
you know especially with what happened
last night with the
nuclear facility in ukraine no sign of
putin stopping and in fact he's telling
macron that he's in this till the end so
i wonder what makes the administration
confident that americans are willing to
you know
pay for the price of ukrainian liberty
uh especially if this is gonna drag on
foreign
sure well to be very clear and i think
you all heard the president convey this
in his speech the other night the reason
why we are seeing volatility in the
global oil markets the reason why the
price of gas is going up is not because
of steps the president has taken they
are because president putin is invading
ukraine and that is creating a great
deal of instability in the global
marketplace so what we are trying to do
and what the president is focused on
doing is taking every step we can to
mitigate the impact of that obviously he
announced the release of uh more
oil from the strategic petroleum reserve
did that in a coordinated way we have a
range of options on the table we are
considering but where we are at in this
moment is certainly we are taking steps
to stand up for democracy stand up for
democracy versus autocracy stand up to
the actions of a brutal dictator uh but
it is because of his actions that we are
in this circumstance um one other
question on the supreme court
reinstating the death penalty for boston
bomber yeah
i wondered i know there's a moratorium
you know on the death penalty the doj
has put in place but are there any other
actions planned or any other steps taken
to
keep the president's pledge to end the
death penalty
well the president certainly supports
the attorney general's decision to issue
a moratorium on federal executions while
it conducts a comprehensive review of
the practice and that practice and
process
is ongoing and the president has
expressed before
that he has deep concerns about whether
capital punishment is consistent with
the values that are fundamental to our
sense of justice and fairness uh
obviously i can't that there's this is a
a case that the department of justice
could certainly speak to um but i could
would just say that um president uh
president uh expressed horror at the
events of the boston marathon bamming at
bombing at the time he believes that
tsarnaev should be punished for
responsibility in the murder of three
innocent people at the marathon for
wounding dozens of others and for his
role in killing two police officers who
are attempting to bring him and his
brother to justice and he knows the deep
pain that his crime caused as the
president said the one year
commemoration of the bombing quote i
know that no memorial no words no act
can fully provide the solace that your
heart still you yearn to acquire uh he
has made clear as i noted his his grave
concerns about uh capital punishment as
implemented but he respects the process
and the ongoing review that is uh being
uh being led by the department of
justice and the attorney general go
ahead thank you overnight we saw the
russians attacked this nuclear
power plant last night
the u.s embassy in kiev noted on twitter
it is a war crime to attack a nuclear
power plant putin's shelling of europe's
largest nuclear plant takes his reign of
terror one step further so just to be
clear is it now the position of the us
government that putin has engaged in war
crimes well we have an internal review
that's been ongoing
prior to last night of to collect
evidence and data of
of the targeting of civilians of the
reported use of
horrific weapons of war
on the ground in ukraine that's an
ongoing process we had not made
conclusions it's a legal review and a
process that goes through the
administration what i will say is that
uh the intentional targeting of
civilians or civilian objects would be
considered a war crime even as we are
assessing that uh regardless of the
legality
this action was the height of
irresponsibility the kremlin must cease
operations
around nuclear infrastructure and we
have of course remaining concerns i
would note that just on the
in the developments that have happened
overnight as it relates to the nuclear
uh power plant i mean obviously the
russian government's actions were
extremely reckless and dangerous they
could have posed a profound threat uh to
the safety of civilians in the region
and beyond we do applaud the ability of
the ukrainian operators to keep all six
reactors in safe conditions while under
attack and to report as they were able
to uh to the nuclear regulator which
certainly was helpful as you know last
night the president not only spoke with
president zielinski he also spoke last
night to the head of the national
nuclear security administration uh for
an update on the situation at the plant
um so that is a piece of positive news
uh for the moment uh but we remain
concerned of course about the fact that
they have clearly taken control of the
plants or it appears so the russian
military has the best step for nuclear
safety would be for russia to
immediately withdraw its fruit its
forces around the facility and on the
hill we've now seen this really sort of
broad range of bipartisan support behind
this legislation to ban russian oil
imports imports the speaker has said
she's all for banning uh russian oil i
guess
just what is your stance on um the
senate bill and is this something the
president would not well i think as we
as we talked about a little bit
yesterday um how the president has been
approaching uh any of the steps we've
taken as it relates to
russia and the actions of russia and
holding president putin accountable is
to take every step to the maximum impact
that will impact president putin the
russian economy i mean the stock market
has been closed now for the longest time
in history russia isn't a full-blown
financial crisis
according to jpmorgan analyst there will
be a co-op collapse in the russian gdp
so clearly those actions are working uh
we will have one of his principles from
the beginning has been to do that in a
unified way in a coordinated way because
we are stronger if we are together as we
work with the europeans the third
principle or another principle i'm not
sure what number i'm on right now uh has
been to uh while we're maximizing the
impact to minimize it on the american
people on uh the global markets on uh
and and certainly we are mindful as we
look at all of these options of of uh
making sure we're not having that impact
so we want to maintain as as dr rouse
said a steady global supply of energy uh
with whatever actions we take
this legislation again we remain in
contact and discussion with members of
congress
we are looking at options we could take
right now to cut u.s consumption of
russian energy but we are very focused
on minimizing the impact to families if
you reduce supply in the global
marketplace you're going to rise raise
gas prices you're going to write the
raise the price of uh oil and that is
something the president is very mindful
of and focused on go ahead cece alluded
to something several officials have you
kind of just did too that there is a
review of options that would allow you
to cut consumption but maintain market
stability and supply can you outline any
of those options in detail that are
under review right now
well uh there are
both international and domestic options
i'm not going to get into too much
detail because our focus is on
discussing what's possible what will
have the maximum impact and not putting
any of them at risk but part of broadly
speaking part of what we're trying to do
internationally is have conversations as
we have been for weeks now with global
suppliers about uh meeting the needs the
supply needs in the marketplace
the reduction of supply the reduction of
oil would raise prices right um so that
is one of the things that we have been
focused on we've talked a little bit
about uh engagements that uh brett
mcgurk has had that almost hochstein
have had uh these are ongoing
discussions there's not a day that goes
by or maybe even an hour that goes by
probably where members of our national
security team and economic team aren't
communicating with their counterparts
around the world about exactly this
issue
there are also a range of domestic
options that are out there obviously the
president announced the release from the
strategic petroleum reserve uh that is
something where the process would just
is just getting going right now uh it
takes a little bit to get that going uh
and then you know he'll consider and
continue to discuss with his team other
steps that we could take domestically
potential for an iran deal factor in to
supply considerations at this point
i would say that the biggest uh priority
with the iran deal is uh having
visibility into and preventing iran from
acquiring a nuclear weapon
obviously as a part of that if you go
back to the uh implementation of the
jcpoa would be the availability of oil
but uh but i would say that our first
and foremost priority focus is on
preventing iran from acquiring a nuclear
weapon and then last one um there was
significant preparation that lead up to
the russian invasion uh in terms of
cyber defenses in the u.s with the
private sector does the u.s intelligence
community have any analysis as to why
there has not been any
offensive russian action on the cyber
front as it pertains to the united
states that's a really good question
phil i don't think anything that i could
provide to you from the podium um i
would say that
the these the cyber preparations as you
noted but just for others you know those
began in earnest back in the fall just
as all of our engagements with foreign
counterparts uh preparations and
discussions about efforts to avoid um uh
challenges in the global uh global oil
markets uh you know making sure we were
unified with our european partners those
engagements with the private sector
began i mean they continued back in the
fall but as it relates to this potential
threat they escalated they increased
back in the fall but in terms of why not
yet i can't speak to that but we are
certainly prepared um if they if that
does happen uh go ahead thanks jen um
president is meeting with the finnish
president shortly yeah does president
biden want finland to join nato that
would be up to leaders of finland and
the nato alliance to determine
senator lindsey graham said last night
that someone ought to assassinate
president
does the white house have any take on
that statement is it helpful at this
point that is not the position of the
united states government and certainly
not a statement you'd hear from come
from the mouth of anybody working in
this administration
it sounds like the vice president is
going to be heading abroad can you tell
us a little bit more about where she'll
be going and what the goal of that trip
will be uh not yet um but uh certainly
the vice president has been deeply
engaged she's obviously already made a
trip to europe i expect there'll be more
soon but i don't have anything to report
out to you at this particular moment and
then finally yesterday you said the us
doesn't have a strategic interest in
reducing the global supply of energy but
now it sounds like the white house
actually is considering
cutting off russian oil imports what
changed is it just this drum beat coming
from both sides of the aisle on capitol
hill that's getting really really loud i
wouldn't say our position has changed in
any way since yesterday um our there
isn't a strategic interest in reducing
global oil supply because that will that
will
increase the price of barrels of oil and
increase gas prices
so we are looking at ways to
um and i said yesterday i believe that
we are looking at ways to reduce uh the
import of russian oil while also making
sure that we are maintaining the global
supply needs out there i don't have
anything to predict in terms of what
that will look like and we of course
remain engaged with with our friends in
congress go ahead thanks jen um there
have been some calls to establish safe
passage corridors for humanitarian aid
purposes is that something that the us
is at all working on and then
how would it be enforced because in 2014
the russians killed a whole bunch of
ukrainians who are trying to play
initially
well we are in close contact contact
with ukrainian leadership to support
their efforts and you're absolutely
right humanitarian corridors are
absolutely critical um to help evacuate
civilians provide urgently needed
humanitarian aid such as food water
medical supplies to ensure civilians can
travel safely we've seen and continue to
see devastating attacks on cities and
infrastructure including schools
hospitals and houses
that are catastrophic uh at the hands of
the russian military so what we need to
see is a sincerity about the
implementation of humanitarian access uh
work to establish that quickly in terms
of the implementation of that i don't
think i have any more details to convey
here but i think uh obviously uh
saying you're going to do humanitarian
corridors or conveying an openness to
that as to your point is very different
from allowing food uh uh you know uh
water medical supplies uh and civilians
to move and certainly there would need
to be an implementation component and
they would need to take the implantation
of it seriously is that something that
then the us is going to discuss with
nato about potentially getting involved
in doing i just don't have more details
on the implementation uh for you to
outline from here uh but certainly uh
you know the establishment and the of
humanitarian corridors uh the the
implementation of it uh the the russian
leadership taking that that effort
seriously would be would be uh something
we would welcome and then um following
up on phil's question about cyber
attacks um obviously it didn't happen
leading up to the invasion but do we
have as the u.s a capability of knowing
whether or not they tried to do
something like that we have a range of
capabilities i'm not going to get into
them from here
and then um
what happens if
you talked about the legal reviews
happening for the war crime element
earlier
what happens next if the review finds
that putin did commit war crimes then
what happens well there's a range of
means i would say first while we have
our own internal review going on and if
we
and as we uh as we continue that we will
provide any information to both the
international criminal court uh the un
other entities that are investigating
from an international standpoint we also
helped pass a resolution at the u.n
human rights council to establish a
commission of inquiry which would be an
entity where we could provide
information that could support future
investigations and also determine to
your question i think accountability
measures
we also joined 44 other countries in
establishing an expert mission through
the osce to investigate possible
violations and abuses of international
human rights and humanitarian law by
russia and its forces so typically
obviously
we have a range of resources here as
other countries do and our our focus
would be feeding that into the
international process in terms of what
you all what you just laid out there and
i know yesterday you said that you
didn't see uh russia being booted from
the u.n security council because they
have a permanent seat how do you
reconcile
the potential that you have you know a
member of the security council that's
flagrantly undermining the charter is
there anything that can be done
especially if he is about to be
committing more crimes well i think
that's part of the accountability
question right jackie and obviously
determination about uh the the future
role of any of any country in an
organization would be up to the the
member countries of that organization we
are one we are not the only one uh but
certainly accountability would be a part
of that process because it would be a
concern for the us or for the un for
their you know sort of
for everything they stand for to have i
think the u.n has been and the vast
majority of countries in the u.n have
been incredibly aligned and outspoken
about uh the horrific uh uh and barbaric
uh actions that they have seen by rush
the russian military and by at the
direction of president putin on the
ground one last one zelinski said
yesterday that um felt like the world
the whole world was too late what's the
president's response to that
i would say that um one president
zielinski has been uh standing up uh
courageously and bravely in a moment
where his country uh his own um security
uh you know his own concerns about his
security are understandably under threat
we have been the united states has
been working for months
to build a global coalition
that will hold president putin
accountable we have been providing a
historic amount of security assistance
military assistance humanitarian
assistance economic assistance
to president zielinski and the ukrainian
leaders and we will certainly continue
to stand by his side go ahead kelly can
you give us any sense of a timeline or a
triggering event that would result in
this policy change regarding russian oil
and any decisions that may be
forthcoming is that imminent or is there
uh
something that you know is there an
event an outside event that you're
waiting for i wouldn't say kelly it's an
outside event i think our continuing
concern continues to be
um
uh you know everybody wants to hold
president putin and the russian
leadership accountable uh everybody
supports the efforts that the pres
president biden has been leading around
the world
to take put in place uh crippling
financial sanctions and they have had an
enormous impact
but what we are also mindful of is not
taking steps that would have the impact
of raising
energy prices raising oil prices raising
gas prices for the american public and
we also are mindful of doing things in a
way that is unified with our partners
around the world can you speak to how
the president has
steeled himself hardened himself if you
will
he's made a commitment not to put
american troops uh in a military
position in ukraine
you've outlined all the steps the u.s
and allies are taking but he's also
watching what is happening as are many
americans who are concerned about the
atrocities that are taking place the
loss of life the civilians that are
being affected
does the us just watch this get worse
is that
what we should all be prepared for
i would just argue we're hardly watching
um we have been we have provided a
billion dollars in military and security
assistance uh in including a range of
defensive weapons that we have expedited
delivery uh to the ukrainian leadership
and ukrainian military we have been the
largest provider of economic and
humanitarian assistance we have rallied
the world to stand up against president
putin we are not watching the president
is leading the world and responding to
this however he is not going to put u.s
military men and women serving on the
front lines of battle in ukraine to
fight russia that has never changed that
has never been his plan never been his
policy and he has no intention of doing
that
go ahead understanding itself position
of the us government but lindsey graham
said last night
what lindsey graham did suggest is that
there's no peaceful resolution here
while vladimir putin with the skill of
power and russia's president share that
view the president believes there
continues to be a diplomatic path
forward that is the path forward that
will help resolve what we're seeing on
the ground president putin has the
ability to de-escalate we have left the
door open uh four months now to uh be
engaged through de-escalation if
de-escalation occurs obviously
humanitarian corridors a ceasefire those
would all be steps that would be
welcomed uh but no we are not advocating
for killing the leader of a foreign
country or regime change that is not the
policy of the united states
iran talks there was a british diplomat
that tweeted this morning that the talks
are close
one of the reported demands of the
iranians is that this administration
reversed the policy of the last one and
removed the irgc from the list of
foreign terrorist organizations what's
the us position on it look there we are
close uh we are making progress um but
we are there's still more work to be
done and i'm just not going to negotiate
from here
go ahead jen the nato secretary general
gave a really
pessimistic assessment of the conflict
he said the days to come are likely to
be worse with more death more suffering
more destruction
is is that an assessment that the white
house shares at this point and is there
concern that the tide may be
turning here in the favor of russia
well i don't know that the tide has ever
turned against them in the sense that
we've seen the ukrainian military
and ukrainian leadership uh act
incredibly courageously bravely
stand up and hold off i think to the
surprise of the world uh the russian
military longer than many would have
assessed possible
but the the ambitions of president putin
have never changed right the efforts of
the russian military to charge towards
kiev have never changed uh so we are
continuing uh and our assessment has not
changed on what their attention
intentions are
zelinski said um
he reiterated his interest in talking to
putin he said he needs to talk to putin
the world needs to talk to putin there
is no other way to stop the war
what conditions does the president need
in order to have a conversation with
putin and does he see any kind of
engagement that putin directly is
constructed at this point for for
president putin i mean for president
biden or for president zolensky
look the president president biden has
no intention at this moment of engaging
directly with president putin he is in
the middle of an escalatory uh war in a
sovereign foreign country this is not
the moment for the president of the
united states to engage directly with
president putin
what i would say is that he leaves the
door open to diplomacy that has never
closed shut there are certainly steps
well i'm not going to outline from here
because we'll have we'll we'll engage on
this through diplomatic channels what
exactly it would look like there are
obvious steps that can be taken
humanitarian corridors a ceasefire those
would all be welcome steps but in terms
of what conditions it's not the moment
now and i can't predict for you if and
when the moment would be
uh the good spoke of course about the
need to confirm nominees in his state of
union speech uh the republicans of the
committee issued a statement yesterday
digging in essentially on sarah
bloomberg and wondering whether the
white house remains committed and
with senator brown and advancing all the
nominees in one slate and if you have
any responses to republicans
yeah we absolutely do all five of our
nominees including sarah bloom raskin
are well qualified for these positions
and we're calling on the senate to
confirm them as soon as possible i think
it's important to remember what is
happening here the republicans are not
showing up to a committee vote if one of
them
showed up there would be a quorum to
have a vote and there are enough votes
to move her past the committee that's
what's happening they're not doing their
job here which is just to show up they
don't have to vote for her they just
have to be in the room which is
essentially what people have elected
them to do so we stand by all of our
nominees we're continuing to engage uh
with um
with senator brown on moving them
forward and certainly we believe at this
moment when inflation is on the minds of
americans when rising costs is on the
minds of americans one thing
that the senate could do is confirm
these nominees
russia has cut off access to facebook
inside of russia
how does that affect u.s efforts does
the white house have concerns about that
source of information to russian
citizens being cut off you know
this is part of their effort uh as you
know i mean to cut off a range of
information from their public um they i
talked about this a little bit yesterday
but there are concerning uh steps they
have taken um to crack down on any form
of information being shared with the
republic certainly facebook is a part of
that they've also threatened fines uh
for journalists reporting on the ground
they've threatened uh they've conveyed
that there are only certain words their
own russian media can use
at the risk of being fined or even
jailed this is a pattern this is not
necessarily a new approach that they
have taken but to crack down on
information
in their country
to reach the russian people uh so
certainly we are deeply concerned about
this and and concerned about the threat
on freedom of speech uh in the country
one other completely unrelated question
uh loved ones who have lost people to
cove and some of them are advocating for
a coveted memorial day or a
physical memorial yeah does the white
house have any view on that would you
support something like that
i think there's no question the
president feels it's important to
remember to memorialize to take a moment
to think of all of the people who have
lost whose lives have been lost and all
of the loved ones who have lost loved
ones he talked about this in the state
of the union right in terms of a
memorial
i would say there's an openness but
right now we're still uh battling the
virus and still battling the pandemic
and working to get funding from congress
to make sure we can continue to do that
and moving towards hopefully getting uh
vaccines approved for kids under five um
so there's more steps we're taking and
and right now i just don't have any
prediction of what that may look like
but certainly memorializing life's loss
is something we are open to
go ahead thanks so much sean um two
questions for you um first of all just
on the idea of a russian ban on
purchasing russian oil the wall street
journal had a pretty good story earlier
this week noting that the price of
russian oil has
declined as the right price of other oil
has increased i mean i wonder how much
of this idea might already be sort of
baked in how much of the pricing might
already be baked in
um
you know whether that is
something that you're thinking of the
white house is thinking about as it's
deciding whether or not to be this bad
you mean how much of it is baked into
the russian economy in terms of having
an impact or exhibits baked into the
rise in oil that you know given that
russian oil prices are going down
and people are and
it's not being purchased out of the
concern that you know there's some
uncertainty about delivery and there's
some uncertainty about you know whether
there could be larger scale bans that
the um consuming prices are all going up
anyway so you're not really losing that
much by banning russian oil because
nobody's really buying it well i think
what most
experts on the global oil oil markets
would say though is that reducing
global oil supply would have an impact
on
the price of barrels of oil and
ultimately gas prices so
that is our concern
now again
we will continue to have a range of
conversations but i think part of our
assessment here is that um while
maximizing the impacts by taking a range
of steps we've already taken uh you know
we are mindful of uh minimizing the
impacts on the public and certainly the
rising price of oil would and the impact
on gas prices is one we are focused on
and just quickly uh there's a washington
post event earlier today where john
bolton said that
trump
may well have withdrawn from nato in a
second term i mean that putin was
waiting for that and i want to
comment on that well i think that's i
saw those comments um you know another
reason why the american people are
uh grateful the majority of the american
people that president biden has not
taken a page out of his predecessor's
playbook as it relates to global
engagement and global leadership because
certainly we could be in a different
place i mean there's no question that
the strength and unity of nato
has been
a powerful force
in this moment and it may take longer
time
to have the the hopeful impact but uh
you know that is the strengthening of
nato we think is no is unquestionably
good for our security here in the united
states and for the global for global
security go ahead john uh jen you said
earlier in the briefing that you'd be
providing information to the
international criminal court about any
war crimes being committed by vladimir
putin um it's long been the position of
this administration that the icc should
not get involved in case in countries
where they don't have jurisdiction
you've made that argument about the us
you've made that argument about israel
do you have a different position when it
comes to russia and if so why i think my
point is that we would provide any
information through our own process that
became available to all of the
international entities that are uh
looking and into and exploring this
exact question so there's no change in
your overall view that they shouldn't
we're not a member of the icc right um
neither is russia uh they are exploring
this there are other entities i
mentioned the uh that we were a part of
uh of moving forward um a commission
through the un which is certainly
another entity that is looking into this
and exploring this question okay and
then on finland um can you confirm that
finland is asking for the united states
support in becoming a major uh
non-member uh ally uh to nato um and
uh would you support that would you
oppose it where are you guys on that
mouthful of the title isn't it i know
you you got it out there though um look
i think the president is meeting uh with
his uh counterpart uh shortly in this
afternoon i will let them speak to what
their aspirations are
and again it would be up to nato uh
the nato alliance to make any
determinations about next steps more
broadly just on kind of security
guarantees to finland i mean they're
kind of in a similar position to ukraine
right they're they're thinking about
what kind of alliances they military
alliances they want to have of the west
and as they're having that conversation
and that thought process russia invaded
one so
does finland need some kind of similar
security guarantees do they need more
security guarantees than ukraine got and
what is the u.s willing to provide
well without getting ahead of the
meeting um i i expect they will discuss
of course the strong history of the u.s
finland's defense relationship which is
complemented by finland's close
relationship with nato uh finland's
current status as an enhanced
opportunity partner for the alliance
helps ensure strong defense and close
security ties in the baltic sea region
uh but again um you know this is a
continuing conversation i'm sure that
their defense and security and our close
ties will be a part of it but we'll let
them have the meeting and then we will
have more to say i'm sure after it
concludes go ahead david
uh just following on the finland thing
briefly before my question i think the
phrase is a major non-nato ally and that
is something the u.s
can designate by itself without having
to go to nato as you suggested pakistan
for example is a major non-nato ally is
that something that we are considering
i i think we're going to let the meeting
take place and then we will have more to
say after the meeting concludes okay um
on your answer before in iran
uh has the president reviewed
the current
draft agreement i understand there are
some issues including some of the iaea
that are going to get
addressed tomorrow when uh the chief of
the iaea is in tehran but has he
reviewed and approved
the agreement as it now spans he has
been regularly briefed on the status of
the negotiations but i'm not going to
get into more specifics beyond that his
belief that any of this has to go to
congress you've gotten that letter from
30 odd members of congress we have
we are aware of the letter um i don't
have anything to convey on that either
let's see where this lands obviously
there's more work to be done pivotal
pieces at the very end uh so i don't
have anything to convey officially on
that the very last is just to follow up
on phil's question
um so
from the question of why it is that we
have not seen more cyber activity by
uh the russians at this point
do you believe that it has to do more
with the defenses as you
passive
described
that wouldn't be able to
affect us or do you think it has to do
with something that was happening inside
bloodshed decisions
uh that they made about when to go use
these weapons
it's not a place i can get into from
here david i would say though we
continue to be prepared we continue to
be prepared for retaliatory act
retaliatory action whether it is cyber
uh or other means um and it's something
we've been preparing for for several
months
glad thanks jim a couple of questions um
president zielinski said yesterday that
if the west is unwilling to put in place
a no-fly zone it should at least provide
ukraine with warplanes so it can defend
itself is that something that the u.s is
considering
we have provided a range of security and
military assistance including defensive
assistance we've recently provided
helicopters that i think my defense
colleagues confirmed earlier today or
yesterday
but i don't have anything
in addition to predict on that front
different topic uh ron klein was on a
podcast yesterday
and he suggested that the president was
considering further extending the
student law monatorium which expires in
may what can you tell us about that when
can we expect a decision and is he
looking at another 90-day extension
uh certainly understand your question
that is obviously something we will
continue to assess and review as we get
closer to may
typically there's a period of time where
you need to make a decision or you at
least need to convey to the lenders uh
what they should prepare for uh but i
don't have anything to predict at this
point in time
um since the math was hearing
it's like hearing your voice on the you
know answering machines
uh since the math rules at the white
house have changed this week has there
been any change to the testing protocols
for the president how regularly is he
getting tested for public uh there have
not been changes to the testing protocol
that i'm aware of i would note that for
all of us
we are still tested if you see the
president you're tested that day
if you're not going to see the president
everybody is on a different version of a
testing protocol have you been tested
since tuesday night state of the union
let me check and we will get the answer
back out to all of you after the
briefing
uh go ahead
ukraine asked for foreign reinforcements
what's the white house position on
volunteer international fighters who
wants to go to ukraine would you
encourage americans go there to fight
over to rather wrong because they are
not protected by
geneva convention and maybe also it
would play in the hand of putin's
narrative of
well our guidance continues to be that
american citizens should not travel to
ukraine for any reason uh so that's
where it stands
good thank you so much a very factual
question first um
could you maybe give us the exact number
of how many russian people and entities
have been sanctioned by the united
states and how it compares to your to
the european union where all together
680 people and 53 entities have been
subjected to i'm sure we can get you
that i don't have it at my fingertips
but let us get that to you after the
briefing another one uh on all the
imports again sorry about that
do i understand it right that
the united states
really won't take that decision
unless the europeans take a similar
decision because europeans rely way more
heavily on russian gas and is that this
idea that making that decision from here
would somehow you know
not
work well with allies well we have from
the beginning taken steps in
coordination uh with our allies and
partners in europe um and that continues
to be the first principle for the
president
and obviously as we're making any
decisions in this space that would apply
but also what also applies to this space
is our our focus and i think the focus
of the europeans as well on not taking
steps that would create increased
volatility in the global oil markets
increase the price of oil a barrel of
oil or increase uh gas prices uh so
we're looking at all of that
go ahead oh good okay guys it's gonna be
less good quickly
so would the president then welcome
iranian oil coming into the united
states in order to increase that supply
again there's not an iran there's not a
deal at this point in time well we're
close we're not there um so uh if and
when we get to that point we can speak
to that question
so yesterday you said you know less oil
supply said again today
uh raises prices and you said ask the um
so i asked the american petroleum
institute about those nine thousand
leases yes you've been talking about the
president and ceo of that group says
that a lot of policies that have been
put in place by this administration
including a ban on new development of
federal lands and federal waters is
really hindering american energy
development during a critical time also
he says the royalty fees increasing on
drilling uh discourages investments are
there any plans to reverse any of these
policies to encourage investment i think
he may have avoided your questions i
mean because the fact is that onshore
alone as of the start of this year the
industry had more than 9 000 unused
approved permits to drill in the united
states and i didn't hear him speak to
that in particular and of the more than
37 million acres under lease offshore
and onshore to the oil and gas industry
nearly 60 percent are currently
non-producing now obviously our view on
drilling over the long term is different
i would suspect than the person you
spoke to which is that what overall we
need to do here is reduce our dependence
on oil europeans are doing that we're
doing that and i think what we're all
going through now in this discussion of
banning oil imports and the volatility
in the global markets oil markets is a
reminder of that so but there's no
shortage of drilling leases that can be
used domestically to enhance production
in this moment they the oil and gas
industry is literally sitting on
stockpiled leases and permits thanks
everyone okay
i'm sorry we i think everybody has to
wrap and go to the next uh engagement
here um but see you all on monday
please gather now in the briefing room
you